[Music]
you've directed the new movie money
monster
it's a thriller and it's set against the
backdrop of Technology and finance the
financial world and I got to watch the
movie today and I really enjoyed it and
I'm curious it's funny because the
movies about so many things but
ultimately in your opinion it's really
about people yeah I mean it's an it is a
very complicated very intelligent movie
you definitely ought to pay attention
while you're watching the film but it
also happens to be kind of a general
public movie that's thrilling and
exciting and all that stuff it's really
arrived you know what's interesting too
is it's about so much that we're talking
about right now which is because the
george clooney is the star and he plays
kind of that jim cramer guy on
television who is telling you about you
know this is the stock to buy this is
the stock to dump and he's very bad he's
a showman you know dancing girls and he
you know makes a fool of himself and has
props and buzzers and things like that
and he's sort of lost himself he sort of
lost himself and he's confronted by
somebody and again I don't wanna give
away too much but he's confronted by
somebody who's really been ruined by
this world right yeah and that's where
every man that's where there's this
confrontation and there's this standoff
and that's where the story really starts
and it's very compelling and T what I
thought was the actually the most
interesting thing about it was that you
get Clooney and you get him to see him
being silly and sort of clownish but
also of course obviously is a great
actor and then you get to see him play
these other layers yeah he really
changes through the course of the movie
I think he's forced to come to grips
with his own shameful failures and he's
he really changes he becomes a human
being by the end of the movie which is
his heroism
well they're great hero in the movie is
Julia Roberts Julia Roberts is producer
director who kind of produces her his
survival what's interesting is that
she's the producer so she's talking to
him she's in his ear for the whole time
so the whole time that he's taken
hostage and going through this
incredible situation Julia Roberts is in
his ear the whole time yes which is a
great dynamic it is a funny thing you
know in this era we have this kind of
weird virtual intimacy and you know
through computers and telephones and all
of that we feel closer to people when
we're watching them on TV than we do
when we're standing the same room and
that's very true the fun
I have constantly a meeting people that
act as if they know me I'm very friendly
in person but they they really do and
it's I think if I was in movies they
wouldn't act that way I think it's very
different when you see people in movies
they're projected in this big way but
when people are in your room in your
bedroom and sometimes I really am in
their bedroom yes but they they come up
and they just hug and there's they're
there right away yeah and the film
explores that in lots of ways visually
as well you know the proportions are all
wrong we see a TV set you know in Times
Square a Jumbotron it's the size of a
giant building and you know that weird
proportion that we have this
relationship that we have television we
have you got George Clooney to dance in
this movie was the one who wanted to do
the dancing he keeps blaming it on me
he's blaming it on you but he was the
one that I think we hate I don't know I
didn't try I didn't do any car out there
it is I don't try at all I just you know
was just making a fool of myself but
well I think there was some there's an
eerie time no there's some yeah he
wanted this he wanted this because he
might be exploring other options
Saturday's career that's right the movie
opens one of the first scenes is when
the first time you see George Clooney
he's sitting on a toilet yes that was
pretty much the first time you see
George Clooney in the movie was that the
first scene that you directed well that
was the first day the first scene yes
what does that like does that is that a
company gift to tell George Clooney into
your your pants are gonna be down in
your on a toilet yeah and your on your
smartphone I know you're a big Hollywood
icon but this is what's gonna happen
yeah there was a little boxer to the
right you know move your ankle there was
a little bit of that first day of
shooting from you for no reason you were
just messing with him no push back on
that
no I think he loved it I think you did
love it
you